I think Bitcoin has a PR problem
sustainability greater in 2020 not Green
problem agree disagree completely
disagree God so I think the big thing we
have to remember is this is the most
secure computing network in the world
right so it is going to take electricity
or power consumption in order to power
that security but the beauty of it is
the miners this decentralized group of
people who are financially incentivized
to provide that security through
computing power they have to go find the
cheapest power sources right that's how
they make money is that there's a spread
there for them and so ultimately what
they're gonna do is seek out cheap
energy sources which is renewable energy
and so what we tend to see around the
globe is people seeking them out yeah
well we just is we see people looking
for the cheapest power which is
renewable power thankfully when it comes
to a lot of renewable power sources
there's excess power generation that
can't be stored somewhere right so
that's obviously one of the big problems
with the battery issues I'm the
uncertainty with it you can't have
consistent energy power whether it's
hydro or wind or whatever it is that
we're talking about and you can't store
solar energy so efficiently either so I
absolutely one of the drawbacks here so
one of the things you can't store it and
then also on top of that you get
infrequent demand spikes right so it's
not always persistent demand when it
comes to Bitcoin mining all of a sudden
now if I have a renewable energy source
I don't have to worry about storing all
that power because I can just install
more machines and I have a persistent
demand at all times I can always have my
machines running consuming power and
securing this blockchain so we've seen
as this explosion of hash rate on the
Bitcoin blockchain continuing that trend
of it being the most secure in the world
but it's using renewable power rather
than kind of non renewables that are
more expensive to actually produce
there's two arguments there there's one
that look this is the most secure option
that people have out there if they come
to understand that and therefore there
is some compensation there is an energy
cost to that and in efficiency cost
in terms of energy but you also told me
that around 70 75 percent of the energy
being used right now is renewable where
that data coming from because there's
fierce criticism when I look around the
world and China of course we know
they're not clean yes there's a lot of
studies that have come out you know I'm
the first to admit that each study every
one can pick and choose what they like
out of it they don't like that etcetera
the general consensus in those studies
is 60 to 80% right so call it 70 75 %
60% 80% whatever the number is it's much
more than people think is renewable
right and on top of that where we see
dollars flowing from the investment
community is into these renewable based
solutions right so whether it's things
around hydro solar you know I've talked
a lot people about using nuclear power
plants they have excess power generation
they can't store it we'll all of a
sudden if it's actually cheaper and
cleaner to use could you start to use
the nuclear power but there's a lot of
options but the best part about this is
there's a financial incentive for miners
to figure out how to innovate in this
space because if they are the leaders
there is a very very big payoff at the
end of it will ever be less energy
intensive I mean I've got some
comparisons here it was a report done
last year the comparable carbon
footprint of Bitcoin mining is New
Zealand's electrical energy use
comparable to the power consumption in
in Chile a waste generation comparable
to Luxembourg nation states in terms of
of energy consumption here in and carbon
footprint can it improve that are you're
saying it doesn't matter it doesn't have
to as long as it's renewable energy
that's being used I think it's two
things right so one is renewable makes
that story very different than if it
wasn't it does and then second is
because it's the most secure computing
network in the world again you expected
to have that high energy consumption but
the hardware is also changing so what
you're seeing is much more energy
efficient Hardware coming into the
market so whether it is through chip
designs or other hardware innovations
again it just takes time to do this
right there's real engineers working
with hardware and there's atoms evolved
and you just have to do scientific work
to figure this out we've seen over last
11 years it improved I don't think
that'll stop
it's just how quickly can they innovate
your cool and Bitcoin is
thousand in 2021 at what point does
bitcoins value become so lucrative that
bigger companies perhaps battery
companies look at this and go hmm
perhaps we can work our way around this
and I know for our technology so one of
the things I think really comes when it
comes to battery technology is everyone
knows that whoever can solve the problem
of storing power will have a massive
market opportunity and where is power
best monetized today one of those is
Bitcoin mining right if you look at you
know I'm an investor in a company that
one of my business partners runs that
essentially takes car tires and turns it
into a number of commodities including
power if you sell that power into the
grid you can sell it for three cents
four cents maybe five cents if you're
really lucky if you then go and you mind
Bitcoin with that same power source you
can generate 25 30 35 40 cents there's a
pretty material increase in the
financial performance of your power
consumption by mining Bitcoin for
selling into the grid even the power
companies are selling their power for 8
9 10 12 13 cents so mining Bitcoin is
actually so lucrative compared to these
other power consumption models that I
think over time more and more of them
will start to move in this direction
we're already seeing some of them start
but I think really when that price rises
over the next kind of 18 to 24 months is
where you're starting to see some really
big companies move into space musk
Loki's got probably some of the best
battery technology in the market and you
know with Tesla if all of a sudden those
power walls either have slow sales in
terms of going to homes or he's able to
figure out some kind of industrial model
you know I'm not one to say that he's
not crazy enough to do it and look and
we know that he's aware of Bitcoin right
he's talked about it he thinks that
paper money's going away so he's very
aware of kind of how all this is playing
out again it's probably a distraction
for them in the short term but at some
point I do think entrepreneurs realize
hey if these Power Packs actually work
how they're promised they could store
power and I can use it to my advantage
to mine Bitcoin it wouldn't surprise me
somebody tries it and you're comfortable
then we've talked about the PR situation
I think you have you don't think you
have I don't have any PR is Bitcoin but
but I don't think a Bitcoin is in a bad
place either
do you think as the conversation about
sustainability and green technology
continues and we're seeing that more and
more even just in the last few months I
do think this is one of the things that
will keep coming up so you're gonna have
to keep her talking about this but you
are comfortable with the store of value
argument the Bitcoin here versus utility
value and transaction speeds because we
did touch on that a little bit in the
live show yeah so I think that store
value is really important that store
value before you can only medium of
exchange intimately the store of value
comes down to two things right one is
security it can't disappear it can't be
hacked etc and Bitcoin being the most
secure computing network in the world is
very secure right so we feel confident
there when it comes to price what you
want to see is over long periods of time
either you're preserving your wealth so
the price stays flat or continues to
increase the monetary policy of Bitcoin
relies on one thing supply and demand
economics artificially cap supply demand
increases price will go up right in US
dollar terms and so again if you zoom
out over the last decades that's
performing asset over the last 12 months
off 150% in the last you know what six
weeks or so it's up 30% so it's
continuing to do exactly what its kind
of built to do now there's high
volatility on an intraday basis and so
people look and oh my god it was up 10%
it's down 6% you know any kind of
emotional volatility in the last three
months and we'll give her crypto though
yeah but but again people who put their
wealth and have a low time preference in
Bitcoin have been rewarded very well
with this store of wealth thesis and so
we tend to think that the non
correlation nutritional assets will
continue to be a valuable kind of aspect
of Bitcoin
especially when you have geopolitical
uncertainty or things like coronavirus
etc where the traditional markets kind
of go into chaos you know bitcoins used
to five or ten percent swings up or down
in a single day I'm Patricia kn'l
markets you know literally people freak
out when that happens and so i think
that bitcoin is i'm kind of better
positioned for the future world that
we're going into over the next couple of
years then i knew the trish classes